Good morning, Hank. It's Friday.
Quick warning. Uh, today's video is not suitable
for young children. Or anyone.
So, Hank, you recently made a video in which
you briefly humped Google. Well, a couple
days later, nerdfighter extraordinaire Mattie
Boosh posted you humping the TARDIS on his
Tumblr and the Humpy Hank phenomenon was born.
Hank, at a historical moment like this, I
am reminded of the great poet, William Butler
Yeats, who famously wrote, "And what rough
Humpy Hank, his hour come round at last, slouches
towards Youtube, to be born?"
Nerdfighter Karen Kavett made that music video.
She's awesome; everyone should subscribe to
her. Hank, I have to go to Amsterdam. I'll
see you on Monday.